growing up I was obsessed with Vanity
Fair Hollywood covers the August
featured directors actors and actresses
all looking super sexy and elegant and
cool and badass but I realized that I
never saw Asian Americans on the cover
and hearing that three of the biggest
names at a media company where Asian
American that was pretty much unheard of
and yet Eugene proved that Asian
Americans can be sexy
Justin proved that Asian Americans are
funny and Ashley proved that Asian
Americans can be awkwardly adorable so I
thought why not retrieve the Vanity Fair
Hollywood covers with all the Asian
American video producers at BuzzFeed
when I first started at BuzzFeed there
were probably two or three Asian
American producers and now there's 22
full-time Asian American producers and
even more interns and fellows so it
really feels amazing to just walk
amongst your peers and to not feel like
you're the only one working in
television where I was the only Asian
person on set this is a completely
different experience it's really nice to
go from a company like Justin was saying
where you know people label you as the
Asian guy or the Asian girl to just
being Ashley or Justin or Jerrod
Michelle Sophia Ryan it's like we all
are individual people here and we're not
just our race and that's part of who we
are but that's not the entirety of who
we are I'm Mellie Lee I'm the
photographer on this photo shoot I'm you
kena I'm makeup artist I'm Yu Jie I'm an
essays I think photos like these is just
captures a moment it just captures a
portrait of their generation and I don't
think we've seen images like these of
Asian Americans finding their identity
through media and just being confident
and owning it I think my biggest
struggle getting into the film industry
is seeing role models that I can
identify with yeah like you said there
wasn't really many people come back up -
there was Bruce Lee Jackie Chan I don't
really know kung fu
I think if you grow up and you watch
media you sort of internalize this idea
that stories about Asian Americans or
your stories are niche or that they're
they don't have space you don't see it
so there's this internalized idea that
your stories don't really belong
anywhere part of getting comfortable
like going into media was sort of
gaining confidence in the
that our stories are worth telling and
that I don't have to be embarrassed so
it's one thing to really dream about
seeing yourself behind the camera at
fine camera but it's another thing
physically seeing other Asian American
filmmakers doing it I think people
underestimate how powerful media is to
kids anything they see in the media is
gonna be normal to them now that this is
gonna be the perceived dorm they could
go forward thinking oh I'm not gonna be
an Asian actor I just want to be an
actor well I just want to make things
and now to be normal for them now so I
think that's really cool I also think
what I like about this is the diversity
of what it means to be Asian sometimes
you'd get an Asian character but it
wasn't fully let you like you said
Michelle a lot of us are mixed we're not
full Asian - and so to see a fully
asian-american portrait to be able to
see people who are mixed and diverse and
still embrace their Asian side is really
cool
can you see a photo like this it means
that you can also grow up to be that
person and take their place and grow up
along those piers usually you see a
photo with like 22 white people and one
Asian person into black people and so to
see an entire photo like this would've
just felt like maybe you don't always
have to be the odd one out seeing a
photo like this as a kid would have told
me that someone like me or who looks
like me can be glamorous things a little
Steven would have been amazed at I mean
not just me being here but like
everybody being here seeing so many
Asians on cameras so cool it's like this
is what white people feel like like I
have Asian directors and Asian
photographers we Asian makeup artists I
was like surprised to see all Asian
casts and all Asian crews it's amazing I
think my younger self would have been
surprised because when I was younger the
only way that I found myself represented
was by watching maybe even Chinese and
watching anime and both pieces of media
were Asian this experiences Asian
American I was just looking at my arm I
think if I saw this as a kid I would
have been really impressed that neither
Michelle nor I waxed our arms before
though my hair is just like floating in
the wind a little bit just
here I think I want to say to you guys
until the asian-american producers here
that I feel so proud to be associated
with you guys
to sometimes be mistaken for you guys
and to just work in a place where we all
get to make content where we all get to
do it together and share to each other
successes I recognize the fact that
everything that I'm able to do that
explores my identity is partially
because of the people who have blazed
that trail performing so I see that I
hear and I appreciate it and that
includes all your piston thank you for
showing me that my story isn't niche
that anyone can relate to it and that it
deserves potatoes where I worked at
BuzzFeed I knew that was a place I
wanted to be because I saw Ashley on
violin I thought that was the coolest
thing ever that the main person is
someone who is similar to me I very much
appreciate working with you guys feeling
safe around you guys yeah I heart
beating heart I really admire your work
when I see your work online I'm like
holy crap did you see what so-and-so did
we're such a good team and we're really
good at supporting each other I'm just
so happy to see that we're all in this
position where we can rise enough
together as community thank you so much
for following your dreams and like
meeting meteor because seeing myself
represented just even here I think it
adds like so much confidence and so much
assuredness for myself we just have to
be our own heroes and heroes to each
other
I'm glad that it you guys could be my
heroes that's really gross I'm sorry I'm
very grateful that everybody here is
here because I think you support each
other and we're there for each other and
we you know we look so nice come [ __ ]
nice we look and we have really good
hearts yeah just like in our hearts it's
good I hope that we've proved that we
can do it you know from 2 to 22 in a
span of what a year and a half two years
it's a pretty exponential growth I'd say
I think that this is almost a
celebration of like cool like we are
here you know don't feel alone in the
coming years I want to see more Asian
Americans everywhere actors directors
good talented Asian creatives in the
coming years I hope to see more Asian
American women in entertainment and I
want to see a more diverse Asian
American experience on camera more Wow
Americans and more like Indian Americans
in Sri Lankan Americans like different
differences in the community
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
started from the bottom now we here